where are you right now Mike I'm in my
hotel oh I'm about ready as soon as this
end the second this ends I am grieving
for the course okay okay yeah I can you
give us an idea of what what the menu
was last night anything interesting last
night last night I never ate dinner you
want to where it was yeah okay I was at
the party last night for a private
aviation company I don't know if I can
give the name sound want to inflict with
one of your sponsors but rickie fowler
Charlie hop over there and hung out
there early and then headed back so that
was the night for me the wheels up party
yes yes I just didn't I didn't want to I
didn't want to hurt any sponsors no I
want to be because I know the show is
obviously supported very well by
corporate America and I didn't want to
step on anyone's toes thank you Mike we
appreciate that would seriously consider
it yeah your friend well that's all that
we wanted to talk to you about just want
to know how your night points last thing
thanks dad have a great weekend
obviously tell me I'm sorry we were
talking about this yesterday with dustin
johnson even this morning hear that you
know the feel is well it's the Masters
like you gotta tough it out somehow and
i was listening to David Duval on the
Golf Channel last night and he said i
wish i would have listened to my body
and I bet you Tiger would say the same
thing I Dustin Johnson with the way he
plays I think did the right thing he
listened to his body I can't modify my
game and then you can really get hurt he
did the right thing but what was the
consensus do you think yesterday I I
agree you know sometimes you get
frustrated by watching 24 hours non-stop
coverage of cable news or of events
because there's no time for context
you're just figuring it out as you're
watching it and we were on Golf Channel
on the live from show and we were trying
to figure out what was going on with
dustin johnson as he's warming up and
we're watching a warm-up ago and well it
looks good oh wait wait a minute she's
going back to get something wrong that
that step swing didn't look good and
you're looking for grimaces on his face
when he's hitting a wagon
it could have been hard for me if you
don't know what it is but you're trying
to read into it and I think if you saw
go on more MORE you never saw him just
comfortable with what he was doing and I
agree with you here's that here's the
fork in the road if you will Dustin
Johnson might never come to the Masters
in better performance shape with three
consecutive wins number one in the world
as confident as he has ever been playing
golf we never be that spot again so you
want to play this tournament in that
mode in that mindset so why give up so
easily well because there were smart
people ride him like you said his
brother and Butch Harmon who I think his
voice was very huge being straight
shooter look if you're not right you
can't go it's a prudent it's a smart
choice it's a long-term choice and at
the end of the day although frustrating
disappointing i'm sure difficult for him
i think i'm agreeing here with you i
think he did absolutely the right thing
if he didn't feel right about I didn't
get the perspective in the moment when
I'm watching charlie hofman play but
then when David Duval and Brandel
Chamblee Frank Nobilo said that's one of
the greatest rounds in the history of
Augusta why is that because with 10
shots better than the average score 10
shots look at the guys who shot 73 74 so
it's one thing if a guy makes a bunch of
birdies if he holds a 40-footer
35-footer makes a 20 28 footer for Eagle
then you go oh my gosh this guy just has
putting boots on and he put it out of
his mind but it was everything with
Charley Hoffman he was in play his
approach shots were close in the wind
given the difficulty of the winner and
dad you've been here a whole bunch
covered it been to the event to Augusta
National when it's windy it's so hard to
get the ball to the right spot it was
explained best by Colin Montgomery on
one of our shoulder earlier this week on
a regular tour event you may have a yard
or maybe five feet of an area where
you're trying to aim for to hit a ball
and Augusta that gets shrunk in half so
imagine that plus the wind and you see
like jordan Spieth making that nine you
just have to be absolutely spot-on with
every yardage
he was given that it was 10 shots better
than the average for the field is only a
field of 93 guys now without Dustin
that's why they said that Charlie said
that last night I think it did get
stopped him last night and he's really
been a good ball-striker in the win over
years and it shows in the tournament's
for these warmer conditions that he's
wanted so he's very very confident
playing in the wind and we'll see if he
holds up today but I I agree those guys
that's about as good as you do give him
the how tough it was for wanted one
individual so I'm going to Mike Tirico
and loan from the Golf Channel today
joining us from Augusta the boys wanted
to know if you can have five wins in a
year or one major one major whatever
okay it's like okay give me good one
this were real quick no God saw Sean
mckee I saw Shaun Micheel in the press
center as I'm walking through he's doing
radio for the BBC and immediately I
think it was shot at Oak Hill when he
won the pga championship he's a PGA
champion for life for life that's it
there are a lot of guys not a lot but a
significant number of guys would want
multiple tournament or even five and a
year's a lot but that one major changes
your life not just in terms of the
amount of money you can make in
endorsements and appearances over the
years but it just changes who you are my
mind in is always and I bring it out for
weeks here and then put it back in the
in the computer 48 weeks here these guys
make a living for weeks a year they make
history and you remember the major
champions you don't remember what Lee
Trevino described to me once is the guy
who won the screen door open you have no
idea who won that 15 years ago but you
know who won majors in 2003 or whatever
2002 15 years you know that rinaldi just
wrote that line down and that will be
used later today with a piano
accompaniment with Tom Rinaldi renault
en dance together LOL sex accommodation
need to go for hello friends i also
wanted to ask you about this with jon
gruden leaves coaching you gets fired by
the buccaneers and eventually goes into
the booth with you monday night football
bigs rage we know that Tony Romo is
going to be going in with Jim Nantz big
stage how much
pre or how many simulated games did you
do with Gruden before he did Monday
Night Football so I think it's a little
different and then I'll answer the
question jaws was still there we had
jaws it was the three of us for two
years I think that that a set entry ramp
that on-ramp to the main job helps
significantly I think I'll make it a
little bit tougher for Tony but I think
you'll I think he'll be really good at
it he may not be as good week 1 z will
be when those guys call the AFC
Championship game but I think he'll be
really good at it what we did during the
off-season we watch games John watched a
lot of broadcast we probably did oh
maybe two or three games off of tape and
in a studio just calling it a voiceover
booth but it's never the same he's not
looking at the field I'm trying to think
I don't think we did a practice game at
a preseason game I know we did with
kornheiser and jaws what will we find
Joe Theismann when we first started so
there are ways get reps you can get
maybe three reps at a studio Laura Moore
and a couple of reps at preseason games
before you do actually even one
preseason game on the air or your first
regular season game so you can you can
get that but again and until it's live
and it's your show it's just not the
same what is the biggest hurdle that
Romo is going to have where to look you
know as a quarterback you know what
you're doing you're reading your keys
but are you looking for different things
that are going to set up the next replay
how do you communicate what you're
seeing and make sure that the production
truck is seeing the same thing that
you're seeing so the replay comes up
because if you wait two three four
seconds you're not going to get the best
replays to explain what happened on a
play so do you have great football
people in your truck do you have a great
set of eyes and are you looking for the
same thing that's one of the magic
things of Jon Gruden and Jay Roth who
produced Monday night with us or now
that I was around them this year and saw
them work Cris Collinsworth in Fred
Goodell use the sunday night football
producer they know what they're looking
for they see the game in similar ways so
when Chris is looking for something or
Freddie's great knowledge of footballs
producer for you know almost a
quarter-century of prime
network coverage those guys know what
they're seeing and that right replay
comes up right away it's a huge
difference maker and that's where that
biggest learning curve comes with an
analyst and a play-by-play and a
producer excuse and also I've tried to
tell people that when you tell a coach
or a former player hate speak for 25
seconds they have no idea what 25
seconds is because they've never been
measured in sound bites like how long
you can go and not go now all of a
sudden you're in the booth or even a
studio analyst and somebody says you got
15 seconds then all of a sudden you
better get to the point and do it in a
way that everybody understands it and
then get out I find that really
difficult for these guys and you've seen
it with analysts that you've worked with
in the studio and I think in the game
environment with the crowd going
statistician over there a spotter over
there play-by-play guy producer in your
ear trying to draw telestrator all that
stuff that just becomes even more
difficult because you're trying to say
in a short sound bite I will say this
day i spoke to tony and we spent some
time together Super Bowl week and I do
that he was considering this I think
he'll really do well there are very few
people who I think could jump right in
to a number one chair and over the
course of the year and I come in the
first week we all get better as we go I
I think Tony will do will do really well
Jim's obviously one of those comfortable
people you could ever work with and very
friendly so that'll be easy for them and
tony is uniquely qualified because he's
been the Cowboys quarterback so do you
do you think criticism on twitter has
been a really father at this point i
mean the guys had everything including
who he was dating and what that date was
wearing in a suite watching a game he's
had that criticized so he's going to be
fine with all that stuff he's smart
telegenic well-spoken knows how to
handle the media III think I think he
will do just fine it's tough it's not
gonna be easy but I think at the end of
the day it'll work out just fine have
some fun today Mike great to talk to you
I will try have a good one pal thank you
buddy the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience